und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend es
stimmt zwar dass durch putins überfall
auf die ukraine die westliche welt neu
zusammen gerückt ist aber ganz so
unverbrüchlich ist die geschlossenheit
ja dann doch auch nicht bei der
europäischen union ist es vor allem
ungarn das ausschert kein öl embargo
gegen russland keine waffen für die
ukraine bei der nato ist es die türkei
wobei sich sowohl bei viktor orban als
auch bei erdogan nicht so genau sagen
lässt ob es ihnen dabei nicht in erster
linie darum geht für sich selbst etwas
heraus zu handeln während roman noch
hoch pokert klang der türkische
präsident heute schon etwas konzilianter
er werde finnland und schweden die tür
zur nato nicht verschließen verhandeln
möchte er aber schon florian neumann
berichtet auf einmal ist er die
hauptperson dieses abends mevlüt
cavusoglu der türkische außenminister
beim nato treffen in berlin der oberste
türkische diplomat weist das hohle
nieselregen und erscheint es beinahe zu
genießen
einer von ihnen stellt jetzt die frage
sie haben ja alle dieselbe es ist die
frage von denen niemand dachte dass man
sie noch stellen müsste das bald hier am
nato hauptquartier die flaggen auch von
schweden und finnland wen würden schien
ausgemacht doch dann meldete gestern die
türkei bedenken an und die irritation
vieler nato partner sie zeigt sich auch
an diesem abend in berlin
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
ein land jetzt die verantwortung
übernimmt und die konsequenzen trägt
wenn man finnland und schweden blockiert
die allianz ist das ganz klar im zeichen
der geschlossenheit gefragt und ich bin
sicher wir können
wie geschlossen ist der westen das thema
überlagert beinahe auch den zweiten tag
des g 7 außenministertreffens an der
ostsee dabei will man doch hier erst
recht eine botschaft der stärke aus
senden an russland
wir haben in unserer heutigen erklärung
deswegen noch einmal sehr sehr deutlich
unterstrichen grenz veränderungen die
russland mit militärischer gewalt
erzwingen wild werden wir niemals
anerkennen jedes demokratische land
meint baerbock noch solle froh sein über
den möglichen nato beitritt von schweden
und finnland also was sagt der türkische
außenminister auf die entsprechende
frage dazu
das problem ist diese zwei länder
unterstützen offen die kurdische pkk und
epg und das sind terrororganisationen
es ist ein vorwurf der auch den
finnischen außenminister überrascht aber
er weiß sein land braucht die zustimmung
von allen um der nato beitreten zu
können einem server switches und ich bin
sicher dass wir in diesem punkt eine
lösung finden werden aber natürlich alle
30 nato-staaten haben die möglichkeit
den beitritt zu stoppen und daher ist es
wichtig dass wir mit allen im gespräch
bleiben schon nächste woche könnte sein
land das bewerbungsschreiben für die
nato abschicken noch heute abend will er
mit seinem türkischen kollegen reden
der wahl kann die ukraine militärische
erfolge vermelden den kampf vom kksv die
zweitgrößte stadt des landes scheint sie
vorerst gewonnen zu haben die russische
armee hat sich aus der stadt region
zurückgezogen
und wie schon an anderen orten die die
russen aufgegeben haben erzählen die
bewohner in den befreiten dörfern und
vororten nun was ihnen während der
besatzung angetan wurde katrin eigendorf
ist für uns alle regionen gefahren wir
sind unterwegs im nordosten von rajiv
überall spuren der zerstörung ein
russischer panzer liegt mitten im dorf
malabo an wo sie wochenlang gekämpft
hatten putin soldaten sollen auch hier
verbrechen begangen haben von denen die
menschen uns erzählen zu ostern kamen
sieben russische soldaten in das haus
alle männer mussten sich bis auf die
unterhosen ausziehen sie haben nach
speziellen kennzeichen gesucht sie haben
gesagt wir müssten unsere telefone
abgeben sie haben meinem mann und meinem
sohn die handys abgenommen und gesagt
wenn wir uns den pin code nicht gibt
werden wir euch erschießen
angst und schrecken hätten die
russischen soldaten ins dorf gebracht am
rande der schule so zeigt uns eine
dorfbewohnerin haben sie einen kameraden
einfach liegen lassen und auch das soll
untersucht werden mehr als 100 ukraine
sollen sie aus wiehl grifka verschleppt
haben bis heute fehlt jede spur von
ihnen wir treffen anatolischen seine
familie folgte den befehl der russischen
soldaten sich in bussen zu sammeln
dort waren mehr als hundert meine
schwiegertochter meine enkelin die
kleine mein sohn und meine frau
und haben sie keinen kontakt nein keine
koordinaten keine daten nichts meine
enkelin das ist besonders schlimm
der familienvater nimmt uns mit ins haus
zeigt uns das zimmer von der uniqa seine
achtjährige enkelin war sein ein und
alles und nun ist nur das foto geblieben
verzeihen sie wenn ich in ihre augen
schaue dann beginne ich zu weinen
ein ganzes leben dass sich der 67
jährige bauer aufgebaut hat liegt in
trümmern zum abschied fragt mich anatoli
ob er mich in den arm nehmen darf mehr
kann ich in diesem augenblick nicht tun
wir fahren weiter richtung norden näher
an die russische grenze
doch hier wollen die ukrainischen
soldaten uns nicht weiter lassen hier
drohen immer wieder russische angriffe
und wir blicken in die usa als donald
trump während seiner amtszeit wichtige
richterposten am supreme court nach
seinem gusto besetzte ahnte man was da
noch kommen würde auch nach seiner
amtszeit
auswahlkriterium schien für die
republikaner vor allem die haltung der
richter kandidaten zum abtreibungsrecht
zu sein ein thema das in den usa immer
wieder geeignet ist für einen
erbitterten kultur kampf darum geht es
jeden die debatte jetzt neu losgetreten
haben wohl letztlich auch um ideologie
um polarisierung im wahlkampf ein motive
sind berichtet aus den usa
sie marschieren für etwas was in ihrem
land trotz allen streits doch als
unumkehrbar galt auch sie hätten nie
gedacht dass sie wieder demonstrieren
müssen mutter nancy und tochter molly in
den 80er jahren als das abtreibungsrecht
schon einmal auf dem spiel stand
da ist eine kleine gruppe von menschen
die andere manipulieren und die lügen
und dann nehmen sie uns unsere rechte
welt
die minderheit will das sagen haben im
land jetzt wird es klar und es ist
erschreckend
viele tausend sind es heute in
washington hunderttausende im ganzen
sie sind aufgebracht auch wegen der
scharfen worte im durch gestochenen
entwurf das urteil von 1973 sei durch
keine verfassungsrechtliche vorschrift
gedeckt ein beispiel für die ausübung
neuer juristischer macht kommt das
urteil so könnte jeder bundesstaat den
schwangerschaftsabbruch selbst regeln
bisher ist der bis zur zwanzigster oder
vierundzwanzigster woche erlangt etwa
die hälfte der staaten will abtreibung
fast unmöglich machen einige wollen gar
frauen bestrafen die in anderen staaten
hilfe suchen jeder soll gegen kliniken
klagen dürfen
wollen wir das recht auf leben in der
verfassung absicht
liberale bundesstaaten connecticut
bieten hilfe suchenden frauen nun einen
gesetzlichen schutz vor klagen rund 60
prozent der amerikaner sind für ein
liberaleres abtreibungsrecht
ihre proteste entladen sich immer wieder
lautstark auch vor den häusern der
bundesrichter die bundesweite regelung
kippen die fünf konservativen richter 3
von trump nominierte bekommen dafür
sogar drohungen im juni soll das urteil
verkündet werden die demonstranten
versprechen einen sommer der wut in der
hoffnung viele menschen zu mobilisieren
für ihre sache und für die
parlamentswahlen im november
zu den debatten in den usa finden sie
bei uns online mehr hintergründe und
videos auf zdf heute und jetzt die
nachrichten von 1 12 die
agrarministerinnen und agrarminister der
g7 staaten haben die entscheidungen
indiens kritisiert den export von weizen
zu untersagen nach abschluss des g 7
treffen sind stuttgart betonte
landwirtschaftsminister özdemir eine
gemeinsame verantwortung gerade der
großen exportnationen auch für den rest
der welt indien ist der zweitgrößte
weizen produzent der welt begründet wird
die entscheidung mit der
versorgungssicherheit des landes
bundesinnenministerium feser sieht eine
beruhigung beim zustrom von
kriegsflüchtlingen aus der ukraine pro
tag kämen derzeit nur noch ungefähr 2000
geflüchtete aus der ukraine in
deutschland an mitte märz waren es noch
15.000 menschen täglich sagte sie der
rheinischen post
zugleich kehrten über die polnisch
ukrainischen grenze inzwischen täglich
20.000 geflüchtete zurück in ihr land
darunter auch menschen aus deutschland
die korona lage in nordkorea hat sich
offenbar weiter verschärft die
staatliche nachrichtenagentur meldete
mehr als
174.000 neuinfektionen sowie 21 weitere
todesfälle staatschef kim chung unreif
während einer dringlichkeitssitzung der
arbeiterpartei zum entschlossenen kampf
gegen das virus auf nordkorea hatte am
donnerstag den ersten corona ausbruch
seit beginn der pandemie bestätigt
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
25 30 34 37 39 49 superzahl 9 und
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 6 und jetzt die wetteraussichten
morgen scheint die meiste zeit die sonne
es gibt ein paar wolken aber nur ganz im
süden entwickeln sich vereinzelt schauer
in der südwesthälfte werden 24 bis 30
grad erreicht sonst 17 bis 24 grad am
montag ist es östlich der elbe
freundlich weiter westlich bringend
gewitter unwettergefahr auch am dienstag
gibt es schauer am mittwoch wieder viel
sonne und an den temperaturen ändert
sich wenig die
berühmten passionsspiele von
oberammergau gehen ja auf die zeit der
pest zurück mit dem frommen spiel wollte
man den lieben gott gnädig stimmen sie
zu verschonen nun mussten die
oberammergauer ihrer festspiele wegen
der pandemie zwei mal verschieben wohl
wissend dass alle frömmigkeit gegen ein
virus leider nicht hilft heute war es
aber endlich wieder soweit große
premiere in oberammergau
zwölf jahre nach der letzten aufführung
und angesichts von krieg und leid mit
ungewollte aktualität
barbara lueg berichtet
leiden
sterben
auferstehen
was ist übrig von dieser großen
geschichte der menschheit was lehrt uns
die erzählung jesu heute ist sie in
unserer welt wichtiger denn je
man denke mal dass die welt wird besser
und die menschen werden klüger und
besser aber das ist anscheinend nicht
der fall also und deswegen ist die
botschaft von jesus eigentlich so
aktuell wie vor 2000 jahren
oberammergau lockt heute wieder tausende
premieren gäste ins festspielhaus das
bayerische dorf als kulisse für die
große passion im zeichen von krise und
krieg was will sie uns sagen
gewalt nicht der letzte wort macht über
andere menschen hatte ich das letzte
wort jesus von nazareth und seine
botschaft sind wird mächtiger und
bleiben wirkmächtig bis zum ende aller
zeiten damit die pest ihren ort
verschont gelobten die bürger
oberammergauer 1633 die
passionsgeschichte alle zehn jahre
aufzuführen seit monaten dirigiert
regisseur christian stückl knapp 2000
leyen darstellerinnen und darsteller
durch dieses weltumspannende e plus er
gilt als theaterfähig katholisch
aufgewachsen aber er hadert weil so viel
leid so mensch gemacht ist
alles auf sich zukommen und sie
werden von den fluten weggerissen
resignation oder hoffnung light oder
trost dieser tag in oberammergau ist
mahnend und
natürlich ist es auch eine geschichte
die in zeiten von krieg nach zwei jahren
pandemie wo wir alle erschöpft sind
verwundert sind auch das herz und die
seele erreicht halleluja am ende wir
wissen es steht die auferstehung und es
ist wohl diese botschaft die jedenfalls
die oberammergauer heute die welt senden
möchten
das was man uns ist folgt das aktuelle
sportstudio und dann auch so gegen 0.15
gibt's die nächste fed express morgan
wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]